Her low freak bitches.
It's God's side job,
fucking children because that's not whatever it is.
It's not working,
but we forgive them.
We will.
It's not all bad.
We don't want to break the whole thing up.
Definitely don't want to do that.
No,
stealing is not that fucking a kid is the same as like some minor bullshit
infraction and society and thousands,
thousands of cases,
maybe even millions of cases.
It's and then still you have these world leaders like Trump met with the pope.
The pope was all bummed out.
Trump should be like,
I'm bummed out to be next to you,
motherfucker.
You represent.
You're mad at me cause I'm pulling out of the climate accord.
What about all the kid fucking bro,
you should bring up the kid fucking he's been fucking kids.
Oh that's right.
You do a good Trump.
Have you seen the pictures of Trump with the pope?
You have to get hopes.
Totally disenchanted.
Rail bumped pope should relax.
He should slow his fucking role.
You're part of a giant kid fucking ring yet.
Who Do you think you are?
Right?
You're getting cocky because the billionaire guy who tricked American to voting
for him,
he's uncomfortable.
Do you know what the thing that bothers me the most is the church is all about
fucking the community and the people.
They don't pay taxes on all this great real estate.
They own tons of it.
How come they can't house homeless people or sick people in those churches all
day long while they're there?
That's free property.
Yeah.
I don't understand.
There it is.
Yeah.
This trumps like my hair looks good.
Good hair day.
It's a good hair day puppy.
Like my hair touch it real.
I got a dead.
The guy that I used went to Tony and guy the hairstylist school.
The color of his hair is like the color of every retired Florida Golfer in his
70 [inaudible] fucking so gross.
He's got this weird blonde grey thing going on.
It's like he moves it around a little,
like some days it's like a darker Brown Sundays.
It's like a blog,
like blonde,
grey.
It looks,
it's just like sand.
He's getting it worked on is what I'm saying.
Like this is not the color of the hair.
Now you do one of two things.
Let me be clear about this.
Either you work on your hair or you don't work on your hair.
Okay,
so either you die your fucking hair or you don't dye your hair.
It's one of those two things.
How fucking when you dye your hair be consistent.
You can't go gray and then be blonde again and be dark haired.
It's too confusing to me.
I need to know what kind of a person are you like how much you working on your
hair?
What's your level of haircare?
How much time you spending putting that together every day?
It does.
Did Donald Trump changes?
Herrick?
Of course.
It was like an obvious.
Of course he did.
He's changed his hair color.
It goes.
He's moving it around.
Just keep moving though.
You don't,
you know,
just talking too much and not moving and I'll do it.
Yeah.
There's not enough happening here.
This complaining about other things happening.
I get it again,
it,
it's not good.
The climate change agreement is a terrible thing to leave.
It's a bad thing to leave his own daughter told them not to leave,
but I never liked Chris and so we got to get out of Paris.
She did.
She has owned his own daughter was like,
this is a bad idea.
This guy's crazy.
He just,
when he is in science,
he is perfectly out of his fucking mind.
He's going against science.
Like the scientists are saying,
Hey,
we've got to reduce emissions hundred percent we're polluting the air.
We breathe.
We're ruining the very air that we need to exist on.
Yup.
Now that's true.
Don't agree.
We buy,
we bought new air.
There's show by chair.
Have you ever seen how much air there is?
Maybe he's doing this because he's about to move.
Move into position to use one of those gigantic building sized air filter
things.
Maybe it's going to have a Trump air filter filters and set them up in every
city.
You could all go back and buy diesel trucks and no one's going to care anymore.
We're going to clean that air.
Nice.
Okay.